don't ask for anything for two years and
you'll probably have a bigger audience
than you can possibly deal with but most
people don't they can't wait for the ask
and if you don't have the value to
provide then you need to go get the
people that have the value it's shifting
from how to to how I so instead of
saying like here's how to build or
whatever it's like well you don't have
the context or The credibility so no
one's going to listen like how to eat
the best breakfast it's like how I ate
my breakfast or the best breakfast that
works for me or my favorite breakfast
and if you make your content from that
way it avoids sounding preachy or
arrogant but I think the real thing is
that I think you're just afraid to make
content and like afraid to wait and
realistically the first three quarters
of them will blow but you'll start to
find a voice to start to find a click
and then you'll get better